it's 3 a.m. and we're going to the
airport
let's go long time you forget that 4
a.m. exists if you haven't been up in a
while at this hour
we're going to Rakesh that's right we're
visiting where I catch everyone it's
pretty interesting so far someone just
grabbed Mars and started putting like
the tattoos I'll leave you for two
seconds I looked away and myosin just
gets affected it's a bit of a culture
shock but it's kind of cool
that's sad there you to go up to it
everything is different here you get a
coke and you get a surprise as well nice
little surprise here on the pizza
I can get the PewDiePie haircut here do
you see it yeah go back
what's that that's great there's just
something going on nearly everywhere
said no about 500-600 times so far I
need to figure out how to say it in
their language cuz no doesn't mean no
here no means I you would be still want
what do they have mannequins everywhere
white show why there's a wall Martin
wants me to film it dude there's a bird
too
the bird is gonna come down and be like
pay us you can't just film this wall
looking that bird that's a massive bird
that's a big bird
big big bird look at that bird
everywhere okay right beautiful the
hotel that's a bit of a contrast from
the outside so we got this trip from
myself parents thank you very much and
rather for a wedding gift an early
wedding yes yes so this is our room this
is our room tour this is our band this
is where we sleep our you know yeah okay
what why don't L you didn't even show we
are writing from the swimming pool very
nice
and then he disappeared and that's the
tour thanks guys
so you leave and the pool is right there
very that big
how do I like I see myself and I know it
rocket
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what up kitty
you find like these really random
beautiful shots or might set in and then
you just look down and it's like okay I
feel like if you're using you filter you
can make this place look amazing
he's gotta know where to like we just
made our first successful haggle and we
saved two pounds
you want to be careful around corners
here look at that so pretty
I bought a can of Pringles and I didn't
get swing swing swing dole nice good
morning
it's day two we're sitting at this very
lovely breakfast very fancy today we're
going to st. little wrong Museum and
that blue building and it's gonna be
happening
[Music]
we're at the fence eateries area now I
think at least this is the line
it's probably is Oh No okay so that was
just a first line this is the second
line
we found the back of the line amazing we
made it to the end guys unbelievable it
was a challenge but we made it here we
are but there's a bamboo forest again
we're back in Japan look at this damn
sit magnifique
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so this garden was bought by a French
painter and then it was taken over by us
on the wrong he restored it with some
other guy that's why they connected some
general I don't know
is he a famous fashion designer then I
don't care what up cat
you know like my bread
he's sleeping next to it
yeah oh poor dog go to the shadow you
dummy
we're going to send the wrong Museum
excited yeah yeah yeah what question
mark excited we already got our ticket
we can skip the line incredible the long
line my family hi we're going to bobble
calf and it better have bubbles or else
Jesus Christ
okay
you sort of forget how crazy it is every
time you go in the hotel and then it's
like oh yeah this is how it is
bird still there chillin you can't
really tell how big it is
big bird very large bird Big Bird
everyone pretty good view to birth
simulator and it's like these now he's a
go
he lives on interpreter I found
jouji filthy Frank I didn't know what
Josie was popular in Morocco Dan oh look
at the tiny can oh look at this
people use trash this [ __ ] here because
why not
I got nothing I'm sorry
I'm sorry it's Saturday but there's
barely any people it's pretty much what
we hope for just a break from all the
madness there's a pirate ship oh my god
we went on the lamest slide and we got
destroyed but let's do the kid slide and
remove this shock from it yeah I don't
know we looked at all the kids and they
went so slow and then we just went I
guess we're heavy I don't think I'm
ready for this Oh Mike it's it even open
they said that you can protect like this
and I'm like why but now I understand
oh it's happening oh my god okay you
only run that one Maricha is that the
one that just opened [ __ ] someone on
the phone with that we're about to do
the most exciting ride of the century
why I can explain what it is
spit random to go to Marrakech just for
a waterpark but I never been to one so
why not say that again Murcia way back
to balls yeah we are on the boats I
smuggled the phone hopefully do it I
won't kick us out what are you doing oh
yeah that's right I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna get burned I'm sorry mom I'm
trying not to
[Music]
let go right freaking now or else
[Music]
[Music]
we are having our proposal dinner in 1
year ago now we're 9 what is our you
predator this lines not yet do you guys
like the Leonardo DiCaprio Matt Damon
haircut
[Music]
[Applause]
what honey
damn you burn girl mom's watching right
now I didn't get burned from the Sun all
right that's the end of the vlog we're
about to go on our private jet
and thank you my catch it's been real
like subscribe and check out Merc have a
great night
see you later okay will bye